Margaret Thatcher: My friends, we have to
remember these repeated lessons of history.
The price of freedom is still, and always
will be, eternal vigilance. Freedom demands
more care and devotion than any other system.
Ronald Reagan: It is time that a voice be raised on behalf of the 73 million pointing
out that profit, property rights, and freedom are inseparable, and you cannot have the third
unless you continue to be entitled to have the first two.
Benazir Bhutto: I come here
tonight to address the new realities and find
opportunity in this phase of tragedy.
Russell Kirk: But American order: freedom, justice, and prosperity,
cannot endure unless America's
public policies are invigorated by imagination.
George H.W. Bush: There was a time, not long
ago when Americans were inspired by elected
leaders, and when they trusted them to do
what was best, and when they believed their
leaders shared their hopes and dreams for
the future.
Phil Gramm: What made you who
you are is the freedom and responsibility
you've had. And if we lose it, it's not just
about prosperity, it's not just about prices,
it's about who we are. It's about our character.